ich bin kein krasser experte aber ich
habe einfach ein gesunden
menschenverstand glaube ich kann das
ganz gut einschätzen ich glaube das
upgrade und lehrern für diese aktion
servus leute herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ich hab ja vor kurzem
ein video gemacht indem ich analysiert
habe ob das kino video von leo
marschieren upgrade fake ist meiner
meinung nach passt aber scheinbar sehen
ist ein paar andere institutionen nicht
so und haben strafanzeige erstattet
deswegen möchte ich heute mit euch über
die frage reden kommen wir marschieren
upgrade jetzt in den knast normalerweise
denkt man sich ja als normaler bürger ok
strafanzeige was passiert bei einer
strafanzeige die kommen wahrscheinlich
im knast rey bei sowas oder das haus
trotz etwas ernstes und genau das möchte
ich heute mit euch diskutieren ich
selbst bin kein jurist ich studiere ich
jura aber hier dass ihr mich für solche
fragen sehr deswegen habe ich ein
bisschen dazu recherchiert und kann
glaub ich euch nicht im bild dazu
abgeben was jetzt wahrscheinlich auf sie
zukommen wird der oberkörper war dass
ich in meiner twitter teilnahmen artikel
gelesen habt und zwar von welt n24 420
jetzt die welt am sonntag kopiert ist
alles andere ist auf jeden fall dreht
sich die ganze sache um die 24 stunden
videos von lehrern marschieren ab und
ihr bestimmt schon wisst da sind ja vor
allen dingen drei sehr wichtig dass im
mcdonald's dass ihm ikea und das im kino
und die drei fälle haben alle für eine
strafe eine andere bedeutung das heißt
wir müssen auf die einzelnen erster fall
mcdonald's der gab es schon ein paar
leute die der anrufe gemacht habe zum
beispiel kuchen tv mutter angerufen und
tom beck ein mittlerweile youtuber aus
meiner community damit auch damals viel
geholfen hat der hat ja auch gute videos
zu gemacht die hab ich euch mal die
beschreibung gepackt könnte ich
anschauen werden noch mehr dazu wissen
wollt und mcdonald's hat gesagt dass sie
sich überlegen eine strafanzeige zu
stellen also mcdonald's ist mit einem
fragezeichen versehen jetzt kann man
sich natürlich fragen ok warum stellt
mcdonald's strafanzeige hier noch nichts
kaputt gemacht habe niemanden
erschrecken man weiter an im laden wie
sie muss man eine strafanzeige stellen
die haben auch niemandem wehgetan und
natürlich stimmt dass sie niemandem
wehgetan haben aber es gibt zwei sehr
wichtige gründe für mcdonald's trotzdem
eine strafanzeige zu stellen nämlich 1
es war trotzdem hausfriedensbruch auch
wenn sie niemandem wehgetan haben auch
in simon erschreckt haben es ist
hausfriedensbruch und hausfriedensbruch
ist ein paragraf für sehr wichtig ist um
ungefähr alle drei von diesen 40 stunden
videos bewerten weil in allen drei
fällen hausfriedensbruch lang wurde aus
friedensprozess in § 123 strafgesetzbuch
festgehalten und jetzt keine sorge leute
nicht aussteigen
die machen jetzt heute keine rechtliche
abhandlung möchte
kurz vor lesen worum es geht in § 123 es
wird keine jura vorlesung der paul graf
sagt wenn die wohnung in die
geschäftsräume oder das befriedete
besetzung eines anderen eindringt wird
mit freiheitsstrafe bis zu einem jahr
oder mit geldstrafe bestraft relativ
klar warum sich dabei handelt eine
wohnung ist es nicht geschäftsräume sind
ziemlich sicher dass ist der relevante
paragraf und die spannende sache ist
freiheitsstrafe bis zu einem jahr oder
geldstrafe so jetzt ist natürlich die
sache das darf ich beruhigen wenn ihr
abo red oder lärm a share fans die dafür
sicher nicht nicht wegen dieser einen
tat nicht nur wegen dem mcdonalds dinge
sofort einen bau wandeln für ein jahr
der ende das bis zu einem jahr ist die
maximalstrafe und die wird er selten
ausgeschöpft also wenn jemand da zum
ersten mal auffällig geworden ist gibt
es in der regel soweit ich das
einschätzen kann hier selten die
maximalstrafe der wirkt als kritisch
weil es leute zum nachahmen motiviert
und weil es bei eventuell die
lebensmittelhygiene im mcdonald's
beeinträchtigen kann klar werden hier
liudger sowie im kino auf einmal immer
bekommt mit in der nacht und sagt okay
ich gehe mal in den kühlschrank von dem
in ein paar pennys rausschmeißer die
selbst die fritteuse dann ist es eine
egal was im moment passiert aber wenn er
zum beispiel den kühlschrank offen lässt
und am nächsten morgen sind die
lebensmittel verdorben und dann kriegen
die kunden am nächsten tag war sie
verdorbene bürger an ist das natürlich
ein gesundheitsrisiko und deswegen kann
man das eigentlich nicht zulassen fall
zwei ikea ikea ist genauso wie
mcdonald's soweit ich das einschätzen
kann fall von hausfriedensbruch also
wieder werden die geschäftsräume eines
anderen widerrechtlich eindringt
freiheitsstrafe bis zu einem jahr oder
mit geldstrafe oder ähnlicher fall
soweit ich das einschätzen kann jetzt
ist natürlich die sache beim ikea geht
eher weniger über lebensmittel auch wenn
die ihre ikea kantine haben da geht es
natürlich erst mal nur mit
hausfriedensbruch vor das problem dabei
ist wieder der nachahmungseffekt also
quasi dass die beiden jungs durch ihre
videos leute dazu motivieren dass selbst
nach zu machen und weil ikea sagt okay
das möchten wir auf gar keinen fall
haben stellen sie strafanzeige ikea hat
eine strafanzeige gestellt das heißt wir
sind bei zwei fällen und bisherige
bilanz von einer eventuellen strafe
zeige und einer definitiven strafanzeige
also soweit jungs gute bilanz dann
kommen wir zu fall drei cinemaxx des
cinemaxx ist ihr euch denken könnt das
kino in dem sie das 24 stunden im kino
eingesperrt video gemacht haben im kino
natürlich ähnlich problematik wieder
können dass hausfriedensbruch sein und
wieder besteht die gefahr dass
eventuelle nachahmer die idee bekommt
das ist eine gute idee ist nachts im
kino einzubrechen obwohl es rechtlich
verboten ist in der
sitzer das kino der betreiber des kinos
das nicht möchten deswegen möchte auch
das cinemaxx in hamburg verhindern dass
leute das nachmachen und stellt
ebenfalls strafanzeige und zwar mit den
worten wir bringen die sache bei der
polizei hamburg zur anzeige
allein schon um unsere gäste und
mitarbeiter zu schützen und die frage
ist warum ist das cinemaxx problematisch
natürlich wie gesagt wieder nachahmer
effekt aber auch die thematik amoklauf
jetzt fragt ihr euch wahrscheinlich
herakles lava der wasserablauf zu tun
weil es einschätzen kann sind kinos
besonders gesichert weil das orte sind
an denen sehr viele menschen
zusammenkommen und an denen sehr viele
menschen angreifbar sei nicht partnerin
sie vielleicht in die schießereien
colorado oder als ein student in einem
batman vorstellung eingedrungen und hat
zwölf menschen erschossen und 38
verletzte klappt deswegen und einfach
aufgrund des allgemeinen
sicherheitsrisikos in kinos da sehr sehr
sehr wachsamen ehemaliger mitbewohner
von mir hat auch im kino gearbeitet
hatten immer davon erzählt wie hoch die
sicherheitsvorschriften im kino sind
dass überall alles überwacht ist
natürlich taschen kontrolliert werden
dass sie eine besondere leitung zur
polizei haben also quasi zum könig
warten wo auf knopfdruck das ganze kino
abgeschottet wird um die kinobesucher zu
schützen was ich sagen will ist dass man
in kinos allgemein sehr sehr vorsichtig
ist und wie das wirkt wenn nachts im
kino zwei gestalten durch die gänge
streichen kann sich natürlich auch jeder
selbst beantworten da möchte ich auch
kurz ein paar worte zum
nachahmungseffekt verlieren weil sich
sicher viele youtuber denken so die
halle aber immer über nachahmungseffekt
aber meine zuschauer die wissen doch es
ist bullshit ist dass sie das nachmachen
sollten tatsache ist meine erfahrung
nach dass viele leute das nicht wissen
ich zum beispiel arbeite einem coaching
programm an meiner uni da arbeiten
studenten mit schülern zusammen um den
zusammenhang mit den schülern den neue
perspektiven zu geben und allgemeinen
den zu zeigen was sie in ihrem leben so
erreichen können sollte dass sie auch
ein studium schaffen können auch wenn
sie gerade eine hauptschule sind und so
weiter und so fort und arbeitet mit zwei
jungs zusammen und ich war letztes mit
denen döner essen und auf einmal fangen
wir an dass sie unbedingt challenges
machen wollen und haben gemeint ja wenn
du eier hast machst du das und das wenn
du es machst du das und das wenn du hast
gehst jetzt zu der der frauen und machst
du blöde an der wachsam youtube
zuschauer hat wenn du hast schon mal
gehört und ich glaube dass es in dem
fall sicher kein zufall ist dass diese
beiden jungs gerade für so dumme changes
den begriff wenn du hast verwenden
ich hab nicht nur ob die beiden jungs am
längsten großen einfluss ich glaube es
gibt sehr sehr sehr sehr viele
jugendliche in deutschland die sich
denken okay beim abmarsch ja das machen
dann ist es wirklich cool
kann das auch wirklich machen
unterschätzt es nicht leute ich glaube
es gibt wirklich wirklich viele
einkommens abschließend zu der frage was
passiert jetzt eigene zeuge werden
deswegen auf dem video geklickt hat
verbissen darum gelabert soll dafür eine
spannende frage wenn es darum geht zu
klären welche strafe jetzt bekommen ob
die in strafe bekommen ist natürlich
wurden sie vielleicht bereits schon mal
wegen sowas angezeigt und das ist gar
nicht so selten leute ich hab letztens
ein video von märz gesehen und bei ebay
managerin die ich richtig cooler typ da
hat irgendwas erzählt von wegen er
musste 1005 euro an den zahlen hier so
und so viel an den zahlen oder kuchen
die frau musste glaube ich auch eine
geldstrafe zahlen also das passiert
durchaus schon das gerichtlich gegen
youtuber vorgang wird und die dann
irgendwie strafe zahlen
das ist nicht unwahrscheinlich und wenn
wir uns an den bombenkrieg von apo-med
erinnern könnte es sein dass da
eventuelle strafe da waren dass er
deswegen schon bekannt ist und es wirkt
sich im großen ganzen einfach nicht
positiv aus also abschließend deute ich
persönlich glaube ich bin kein krasser
experte aber ich habe einfach ein
gesunden menschenverstand glaube ich
kann das ganz gut einschätzen ich glaube
das abklären was er für diese aktion
nicht in den knast gehen werden aber es
kann durchaus sein dass deswegen eine
saftige geldstrafe auf sie zukommt also
abschließt leute noch massiv wird ist
leider aus warum ich hatte definitiv
gehört zum punkt kommen sollen aber ich
lasse mich bei so was immer in rage und
dann geht's einfach nur bei mir schreibt
man in die kommentare was irgendwelche
strafe bekommen leeren maschine und
apa/red für diese 24 stunden videos
diese drei stücke hoffe die strafe in
euren augen sein und hielt ihr überhaupt
sie sollten dafür bestraft werden reiter
kommen dann checke dauert in einem neuen
job bekommen